hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to infinity er now big
warning this game has a lot of flashing
colors so watch out if you're any sort
of epileptic please watch with care now
not being said I really don't know who
made this game or wire or for what
purpose I'm assuming to do some oh [ __ ]
Oh again I don't really know why or how
all I know is that you're trying to
cross the road so if any of you have
ever played uh I think your actual game
is called crossing road on the phone
device the mobile the mobile game it's
really a lot of fun and really
simplistic and this is kind of like that
but the only problem is I can't really
see where I'm going and my blood is
still on the road I did not know though
to be that way
[ __ ] I didn't knew that oh yeah my body
went twitching off into the distance so
there's not a lot of point of the game
[ __ ] god damn it so there's not a
lot of point of the game it is just like
trying to get across the road holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] ok can I just jump
over these why can't I just do that
seems like okay there seems to be the
sounds of chaos
through the hillside but I'm alive and
that's all that matters
I also don't know if there's an end of
this game oh hello bunnies how's it
doing how you doing gonna follow me
across the road oh boy
you got spiral eyes you're hypnotized by
my spiral tower sure of you guys don't
get moidered
huh why did they dodge oh it's a
never-ending party doom the jam and
purgatory forever
what so there is a limitation on what
I'm doing here okay off I go Oh bollocks
sorry I was sixth about to cross you
needn't have panic so much oh sure
sorry here's me a deer blows my eyeballs
those are my hot bubbles windfall [ __ ]
to infinity R whoa whoa oh the deer puns
they're amazing snap okay we're fine
they're not lumps line and that's all
that matters my god
whoa did you see that dodge I don't know
what else you would have been looking at
but weren't you looking at me why don't
you look at right I get a little jealous
when people are watching me being
infinity er come on long bunnies hop to
it bun buns careful look both ways
bunnies get out here get on the road I
don't know why I'm encouraging you to
get on the road excuse me bun buns
coming through
we're going to survive Hey okey-dokey
then
Wow bun bun other bun bun come with me
please
please don't die
Oh God we're gonna be okay it's Bambi
and supper maybe it's a back they both
died it's so horrible
do I have to guide him over where's my
bun buns do I not have bun buns is okay
all righty then I didn't think I don't
know what I did but I did it I did it
somehow I know okay all right lesson
number 77 don't stop to mourn your
fellow animals all right okay go go go
go go go go God bunnies is that bun buns
come along bannon's I'll protect you
don't worry whoa I think one of the bun
buns is narrowly avoid oh come along
thumper we're gonna be fine oh don't
mind the hay-bale or the flying skull of
your lost friend come on come on you're
almost there come on huh
okay bun buns hon minds oh my god three
bun buns come along bun buns we're gonna
be whoa oh no no my buns I think that's
very evident I can't even care for my oh
oh
cheesy chase what the hell excuse you
sir don't you dare do any of that
Oh long-long dears I don't hear the walk
why I did not deserve that damn it ah
God I was saved with divine intervention
and then I threw it all away
Oh nike's oh oh come on bunch of
[ __ ] we gotta got my bun buns we're
gonna have fun fun we're gonna go to the
moon man whoa there's my skull these
damn humans ah they think they own the
place
stop running over my body carefully
carefully if you all could hurry up well
my bonbons mine be dead dead I'm gonna
get one of you I'm gonna bother you
bastards across the street whether it's
might be the death of me might also more
likely be the death of you Wow
let's just saw a tiny skull I didn't
know my bun buns were already dead I
went backwards I went backwards
maybe rushing I know
little bang okay got it okay come on
stop it we gotta get down what does hot
hot damn itself of dicks ah burn burn
burn burn burn burn burn burn burn who
burns burns burns burns burns burns
burns burns burns burns burns burns
where's the goddamn where's it burns
boys come on just cuz I was going to a
haptic [ __ ] pattern doesn't mean he
needed to hit me ha okay I'm done
all right so this is infinite ear I
could play this for a while it's
actually really fun this game is free or
it's pay your own price obviously it was
made in a jam so decide whatever price
you think is fair if you don't want to
pay anything that's totally your option
if you want to pay a buck or two
feel free thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video bye bye